what the vaccine
enables people to go along with more
easily is the idea of a health passport
or vaccine passport and that passport
becomes a gateway to a digital id that's
connected to your ability to participate
in society so it is the beginning of a
social credit system it is the back door
into a social credit system
you're going to need to have some way to
prove you're vaccinated
if we're going to have freedom to travel
so the biggest reason to get a vaccine
passport going is many countries are
saying you can't come in here unless
you're vaccinated
welcome to episode 130 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode of opposing views i had
arthur kaplan and james lindsey on to
discuss covid19 vaccine passports we
covered topics like the passport
proposals themselves current
restrictions in different u.s states the
potential impact of amplifying
governmental control and social credit
systems james lindsey my first guest is
an american author cultural critic and
mathematician who's spent a significant
amount of time in woke culture
especially among writers or in the
written community
he had the opportunity to study you
could say the main tenets of their
literature and to gain a broader
perspective on social changes both in
the us and worldwide
arthur kaplan is a professor and
founding head of the division of medical
ethics at nyu grossman school of
medicine his focus is on research in
bioethics transplantation and health
reform so these topics are right up his
alley you'll see he had a very different
perspective on what's behind vaccine
passports so make sure you stick around
long enough to see that contrast it's
really interesting and do remember to
hit subscribe if you enjoy this episode
or the opposing views format or want to
see more
james lindsay welcome to the podcast hey
thanks for having me
this should be a good one before we get
started can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
that's a mysterious topic it's harder
than you think to give a brief
background of who i am and what i do um
i have a phd in math and before that i
get a degree in physics so my background
educationally is in the sciences the
hard sciences and mathematics so lots of
you know formal logic et cetera uh lots
of pattern recognition um that kind of
thing what mathematicians do i guess
and uh
through the course of the previous
decade i stumbled into this woke stuff
happening and i started to think that it
was absurd
and so together with a colleague peter
pagosian we decided that they were ripe
for an academic hoax in 2016 and 17
which we wrote and it was called the
conceptual penis as a social construct
we submitted that and it was accepted by
a very low ranking potentially predatory
journal probably predatory journal
called cogent social sciences
it's really funny it turns out it's
going to be one of the funniest things
i've ever what was it called the
conceptual penis as a social construct
so the argument was that penises don't
really exist
but that they cause all the problems in
the world including climate change and
so we should think of them as a social
construct that leads to machismo
braggadocio in all men
and
it's really lewd it's a really
horrifically
lewd
piece of academic writing and it we sent
it to a journal that did not accept it
and then they forwarded it internally to
what amounts to a predatory journal
under the same publishing company and so
there was a scandal there but we picked
at the wrong scandal and said that we
had pulled a satire on gender studies
and made a big big hay out of that and
we got a lot of criticism
and we took that criticism seriously
both friendly criticism and not so
friendly criticism in fact vile
criticism we took we just took that as a
we didn't take it personally we just
took it as a road map so oh if we wanted
to prove our point about gender studies
and woke scholarship in general
that's what we have to do to satisfy the
other side they told us what it would
take so let's do that so then we spent
all of 2017 and 18 writing 20 more
academic papers
um
the you know the most famous of these is
about
that we can control rape culture by
studying dog sex in
in the dog park and how people react to
it those human reactions to queer
performativity and
canine rape culture in urban dog parks
in portland oregon was the title of that
paper and we concluded that we should
train men though that we trained dogs we
rewrote a chapter of hitler's mein kampf
as intersectional feminism that was
accepted by a social work journal
we ended up getting seven papers
accepted one of which the dog sex paper
won an award for excellence in
scholarship by the leading journal in
the discipline
and we did that in the course of a
little over a year
and at that point we became
international spokespeople for what in
the world is going on in woke
scholarship so
we figured you know it was a crash
course to do that we didn't know woke
scholarship well when we started but
obviously we got good enough where we
could publish at the research level so
we knew a little bit by the time we were
done with that project so peter diverted
his energies into another project he had
had on the back burner and helen pluck
rose and i
uh the other of our trio
set to really digging into the woke
literature and i'd keep describing it as
saying
it's like if you bought a new property
kind of out in the woods and you you
know you clean up the shed and you clean
up this and you you know tidy up that
and you fix the garden or you do
whatever you get the house in order but
there's been that tarp over something in
the backyard when you just left it to
last and you finally look under the tarp
and you're like look dead bodies
and it was like finding dead bodies to
the the dead bodies rotting in the well
really poisoning our society to see what
was in
the scholarship
and so i remember at that time saying oh
my gosh
you know this is like
possibly civilizational
collapse
somebody has to do something about this
and so i actually quit my job and
started studying this stuff full time
like i was attempting to independently
do you know phd level research to
understand i'm reading papers and books
reading them multiple times taking notes
trying to learn
everything i can as fast as i can about
the
the woke scholarship the critical social
justice scholarship and i started a
company at the beginning of 2020 uh kind
of media and information i don't know a
media platform or something called new
discourses it's newdiscourses.com where
i basically take my what i'm learning
and put it out in the world as fast as i
can publish it so pardon the typos i
don't have time to edit
and so uh
so i'm trying to get this information
out of the world as fast as possible so
my background is mathematician turned
prankster turned horrified by what i saw
turned probably the
i would say it's it's fair to say that i
may be a leading if not the leading
scholar
on
most things woke literature but
especially critical race theory from
outside
of the umbrella of people who believe it
and i've been doing that full-time ever
since and now i travel all over the
place and tell people not just putting
it on the internet
okay wow that was a wild story you know
like whether to laugh or to cry
right horrifying i travel as much as
your dad was but it's like
it's a significant fraction uh you know
i've had
nearly 80 flights this year uh and
that's with covid and everything else so
i've been getting around
wow
okay well i brought you on this episode
to talk about vaccine
passports
can do specifically
uh
and i chose you because you've got a
logical mind i thought you'd
you show one side properly
so
i think we should jump right in that's
pretty intense though it's pretty
intense okay so first off starting with
vac the mandatory vaccine passports that
you see popping up everywhere so my
first question here
is
according to you is this uh vaccine
mandate and these passports is it the
end is it the end of covid or the
beginning of something worse it's the
beginning of something worse the the
kovid's irrelevant to it i mean it's
now the evidence has
come out
nearly inc
incontrovertibly it's just absolutely
conclusive that there's what was a
harvard study that came out just last
week and it said that there's no
statistical correlation of any
meaningful
stature between vaccination rates or
vaccination percentages in different
countries or states and rates of covid
we see so-called breakthrough cases
all kinds of all over the place natural
immunity got completely ignored um
they still want vaccines even if you
have negative tests
you get your vaccine you still have to
wear a mask no the mask doesn't do
anything in the first place almost i
mean very very little and so it's all
pretext
it's all pretext but what a vaccine does
or develop the vaccine itself what the
vaccine
enables people to go along with more
easily is the idea of a health passport
or vaccine passport and that passport
becomes a gateway to a digital id that's
connected to your ability to participate
in society so it is the beginning of a
social credit system it is the back door
into a social credit system like what we
see in china which is effectively
totalitarian under theirs
it's not to say that people in china
can't live a relatively good life
but they are bound by this they have to
say the right things not say the wrong
things they have to spend time with the
right people not spend time with the
wrong people they have to you know do
all these kinds of things to manage
their social credit score or they find
that their ability to
use their their resources their money or
whatever to take a trip or to get on a
train or to get on a plane or whatever
it happens to be can be pretty severely
curtailed um it can be very easily
expanded to the point where depending on
your social credit score things cost
more or less for you it can be a you
know a discount rate if you have a good
propaganda score um because that's how
you raise your social credit scores
behaving the way the government tells
you to and sometimes literally by
watching propaganda videos on your
device and so if you participate in this
they can make it to where your groceries
cost 50 less and if you refuse to
participate in this or if you go against
it they might cost 50 more and so they
can really put a lot of social leverage
on people
and also they ban things like people
getting together in large numbers unless
it's government sanctioned and there's
government representatives there
watching it it is the back door to
something far worse the vaccine itself
whether it's absolutely worthless
whether it's slightly valuable whether
it's extremely valuable turns out to be
irrelevant to this question
the
the vaccine
is not going to end the pandemic because
the pandemic is being used to
install social control and the social
control is being used basically to
leverage people those of whom have the
vaccine so they shrug their shoulders
and say well
i already have it so i already have the
vaccine so whatever uh to to get the
vaccine passport the vaccine passport is
designed to get people to start to
participate in something digital in
their phone that's connected to their id
that controls their ability to
participate in society to buy and to
sell to go and to travel to enter and to
you know leave you see for example and
what is it in ottawa in canada and all
over australia you can't leave unless
you you do all the things they tell you
you get vaccinated and do all this other
other stuff
um
so there's total is just a back door to
a total social control system which will
begin there and if they can
if they can do it for whether or not
you've taken an injection they can start
to do it for other things it could be
your body mass index it could be whether
or not you are
uh
you know did you support the january
sixth insurrection in some way online
well now you're a domestic terrorist are
you a mother or a father showing up to a
school board and complaining about what
they're teaching well now you're a
domestic terrorist and so if you have a
digital passport system that can control
your access to society it's very easy to
put a lot of pressure and leverage on
those people we are seeing the dawn of
totalitarianism in the west and the
vaccine passport is the back door to it
now the vaccine itself clearly the the
data have come in is not adequate to end
the pandemic as it were and in fact it's
seeming to be that it may actually be
making it worse it's probably driving if
you understand biology it's driving the
variance the variance may become worse
or less bad depending on how
evolutionary processes work and in this
case
antibody dependent enhancement can make
some very scary variants that may be
coming down the pike and so everything
about this
it seems to be pretext and the pretext
is for what well the passports and the
passports are for what a backdoor to a
social control system like we see in the
model exists like we see in china
okay so then what's your response to
people that say that sounds like a very
complicated conspiracy theory
that it's already happening
and it's literally published that this
is the intention
um
if you go to the world economic forum
website it's actually on there
there's a there was a book written and i
think in the 40s called the open
conspiracy
that suggests that you can get away with
a gigantic scary computer conspiracy if
you just talk about it because then
people think well conspiracy would be
happening in secret behind closed doors
they wouldn't tell us that they must
have some other intention and so that's
um
what i would say to that is
it's it's out it's not even hidden you
know the the director of the world
economic forum claus schwab at the very
beginning of the pandemic on canal a
quickly published a book called by june
of last year published a book called
covet 19 the great reset where he
explains that we have a very narrow
window to reset the entire world and its
economy and its approach to social
management and everything
through covid19 and
this is
that's not a conspiracy that's actually
an organization that's openly telling
you what their goals are and why they're
doing it
if they don't want to believe that i
guess that's on them but i encourage
them to go read it this is the same
thing with the so i'm famous with the
woke literature right and i always like
literally sitting here right next to me
right next to me i have a famous woke
education book why because
if you follow my podcast
most of what i do on my podcast i don't
sit here and talk to this microphone and
just pontificate i read the woke
literature to people and say what i
think about it and i always encourage
people listen don't believe me there's a
great chance i'm wrong i think most
people
most people are well intended and kind
of dumb that includes really smart
people and so we make mistakes we get
things wrong i encourage people then to
go read it for themselves i i give
people access to the degree that it's
legal you know i can't give people the
books i can't publish republish a book
but you know i give people access this
is the book i took this from go read it
yourself see if you draw the same
conclusion
draw your own conclusion argue with me
discuss with me whatever it is same
thing with this go read what klaus
schwab has written about the fourth
industrial revolution what clash royale
is written about covet 19 and the great
reset what the world economic forum is
doing what how all of this ends up
aligning with the so-called build back
better program that we don't just hear
from joe biden or from justin trudeau we
hear it from boris johnson we hear it
from an uncanny number of world leaders
all kind of in
in unison all at once
you can actually read these things
yourself and if you want to
disagree that's fine but i seriously
encourage people to actually go read
what's written first klaus schwab's
books are not hard to read they're just
annoying because they're all kind of
that empty corporate jargon
but they're not hard to read you know i
read the great reset and coven 19 the
great reset in something like you know
half a day or something it's not a
difficult book and you can just see it
go to his website go to the world
economic forum website and see what
they're publishing it's constantly like
you're going to eat bugs
you're going to live in a pod you know
all this weird like
they put out a video in 2016 in fact it
said
after the great you know to advertise
for the great reset a video it went
viral and it said the first thing you
know coming by 2030 or whatever what's
the future going to look like they said
you will own nothing and you will be
happy everything you have will be will
be rented
western values will have been pushed
beyond their breaking point now they
literally list six or eight points of
just crazy stuff that people would say
is a total conspiracy theory um
i encourage people to just go go engage
with it see what you think why did they
put this ask the question simply be open
why did they put this out why on earth
are people like you know
they made a video not that long ago
where they had a whole bunch of people
like in a room and it said like you know
the great reset whatever and it's got a
picture of joe biden it's got a picture
of george w bush it's got a picture of
ivanka trump like
those are the people involved what's
going on just go look for yourself then
watch the scary video that they tell you
what they're talking about what they're
doing constantly warning about cyborg
this schwab's been warned about the
virus before there was a virus he warned
about cyber attacks before there were
cyber attacks he warned about supply
chain disruptions before there were
supply chain disruptions
if it's not
if it's not a conspiracy that's fine but
you should probably go look at it at
least before you just dismiss it out of
hand these guys have been publishing
this crap since the 70s telling people
what their what their plans are so i
encourage what would i say to people who
say that sounds like conspiracy theory i
would say go read what they've written
about it just go read in their own words
major organizations that are tied up
with major corporations
larry fink of blackrock is deeply
embedded in this for example and see
what's there
just see
that's horrifying i regret doing this
podcast so early in the morning
[Laughter]
so
do you think the reason that this is
being
so say say this is true and this is
being implemented is the reason it's
being implemented to keep people safe
i mean what do you mean by safe i don't
mean to be the philosopher in the room
but yes uh
their goal their their justification is
through safety
because they believe as the neo-marxists
pointed out for example max horkheimer
pointed out that
freedom and justice these being kind of
key words are dialectical concepts
that's what he said the existing
contradiction so that the more freedom
that you have the less justice that you
have and the more justice that you have
the more freedom that you're the less
the more justice the less freedom and
back back and forth so max horkheimer
actually said this he was the
third director of the frankfurt school
of critical theory
he is the person who named critical
theory he invented the idea of critical
theory out of marx's critical philosophy
uh he said that he was correcting for
some of the errors of marx one of marx's
era errors he said was that freedom and
justice uh
are dialectical and marx thought that
you would as you get more justice you
will get more freedom and this is where
you have to understand that justice
means justice according to communist
terms so justice means communism
so what he's actually saying is that
if you want justice is going to contain
safety if you want to
if you want to look at that safety and
and
freedom are
in opposition to one another
and so to keep people safe or to exert
social control are really in some sense
part and parcel the same thing it's just
a matter of justifications
and so this is
like i said that's 1969 when horkheimer
explained that in an interview as he
said his entire critical theory is based
on that so yes the justification is to
keep people safe just like before the
french revolution
it was the the committee of public
safety that
did the reign of terror uh it was to
keep people safe it was for their best
interests you know the technocrats or
the aristocrats at the time whoever it
was going to keep everybody else safe on
their terms and that's what it really
boils down to is that they're going to
keep people safe from themselves because
they think that they're
smarter than everybody and the little
lords of the earth or whatever else and
that they're going to you know tell
people what it requires of them to be
safe it's not very safe for example if
there's social unrest so what do you
have to do you have to figure out ways
to completely
do kind of the the socialist
redistribution program
not just economically but now in terms
of power and privilege and access we
call that equity and so now we're gonna
have worldwide equity programs that
redistribute resources power privilege
et cetera not just
access to the means of production and uh
that will help stabilize things oh if
we're gonna keep people safe we have to
keep them safe from these viruses i just
saw that spain came out and said that
it's not enough to wear masks for
covid we have to continue to do this
until we stamp out the flu now
so now we have to continue all of this
medical tyranny because of the flu
which has obviously been a thing people
have been living with for a very long
time and i saw another uh
article just yesterday or the day before
that said we didn't just you know
take precautions against covid we
basically stamped out the flu they say
that the flu didn't happen in 2020 they
have documented i think quite falsely i
have a personal reason for believing
this that there were some 2000 cases of
flu in the past year of course the pcr
tests that they were using at the number
of cycles the detection sensitivity that
they were running it can't really
distinguish covid from flu and so how
many yeah yeah so you have that issue
and then
simultaneously i got the flu
so this is what i don't understand i
just told you in a minute ago that i
travel all over the country talking all
over the place i go to all these
meetings all these conferences in
contact with hundreds or thousands of
people regularly
somehow it appears that despite there
being millions upon millions upon
millions and oh my gosh pandemic numbers
of cases of covid
i somehow managed not to get covered
with all of these huge public super
spreader events or whatever that i went
to
but there are only 2 000 cases of flu
but somehow i got the flu
that's weird how did i get something
literally that rare and i got i mean i
actually thought i had covered so i went
to the doctor and i got diagnosed i had
the flu and so
you know they did the test and flew so i
and it felt like flu and it acted like
flu and it probably was flu and so
you know
what are they trying to keep us safe
from they're trying to keep us safe from
everything
you know the and of course it's one of
your your dad's best messages is that
you're always in this kind of trade-off
between between risks
right it's one of the things i admire of
his message the most
is that um
there's a risk in trying to protect
yourself and there's a risk in not
trying to protect yourself if we're
going to put it in this specific context
so if you if you don't protect yourself
from flu then you might get flu you're
taking that risk but if you decide to
protect yourself from flu or covid or
car accidents or whatever else then
you're going to take a different risk
and the risk that we take with regard to
these things is destroying our
livelihoods destroying our economy uh
massive amounts of of death by suicide
from people who've been socially
isolated for so long and feel like
there's no way out massive increases in
substance abuse overdose deaths other
deaths of despair
we see
now
although you're not allowed to mention
them they apparently don't exist vaccine
injuries
the the vares data is
granted it's
not
rigorously collected it's anybody can go
file a claim
so it's a quite open question of what's
in there to some degree but the verse
data is concerning and
oddly enough they're pretending that the
vares data is not concerning and so
there's a trade-off of risks and so they
say it's about safety but the question
is you know
what are we trying to keep ourselves
safe from and what are we
losing or what are we what are we paying
with to buy that alleged safety so maybe
we do make ourselves safe from flu but
is it worth say all having to stay
living in our own houses in
borderline never being allowed to leave
and having to make sure that you know
stores don't really exist for us to go
out into the public square and interact
in person because we can just order it
on amazon have it delivered
which is to amazon's great benefit of
course
what are we losing in order to buy that
safety and the the thing is is you
always have to ask where is that
reasonable line
where is the reasonable line where are
you going to say no the risk is worth it
the risk to think for yourself the risk
take your own action there is to get in
a car even though it's one of the most
dangerous things most people do on a
day-to-day basis even they don't think
about it there is to get in a car and
drive where you will under your own
power you know they can take that away
in the name of safety as well we could
either just curtail how much people
drive by making it very expensive
through odd gasoline taxes or mileage
taxes like they're attempting in the
united states you could also transition
to driverless cars and so your car
drives itself maybe it doesn't even have
a steering wheel that you can control
they get the ai technology sufficiently
good then what well you get in your car
and you say well i want to go to the
grocery store and you push it in there
and for some reason they don't want you
go to the grocery store and your car
drives you to the police station instead
where you're questioned for something
you put on twitter and you can't control
your car because you don't have the
freedom to control your car because your
car isn't driven by you what are you
trading i'm not saying that it's
necessarily going to happen that's
certainly possible
it's or you know even with these cyber
attacks from
schwab due to cyber attacks because
cyber attack your car
drive you off a bridge
somebody could hack your self-driving
car and kill you
what are you trading in the name of
safety and
what you are
often what you're often
trading is another kind of unsafety
you're you're putting a different risk
into the equation and people are not
usually good at think unfortunately
thinking through
and balancing risks and saying some
level of risk is always going to happen
so therefore some level of risk always
has to be acceptable and that in fact
what causes the most happiness and
flourishment is to allow people to make
the decisions for themselves about how
much risk they're willing to take for
example if you're afraid of covid and
you want to get the vaccine and you want
to wear two masks and a face shield and
whatever else and do you want to dress
in a garbage bag i've seen somebody
wearing ppe in public before which is
hilarious
good that's your decision that's your
decision you want to have you never want
to leave your house i have a family
member who left his house nine times
during the during the entire uh time
from pandemic lockdown in march of 2020
until the vaccine was available to him
in summer of 2021 so for something like
14 months he left his house wow nine
times if that's what you think you need
to feel safe that's a decision you
should be able to make of course what
was a trade-off you know he lost
all that opportunity a year of his life
to spend time with friends to connect to
get out whatever mental health toll that
took on him i don't know
that but there's a trade-off there but
if that's what you want to do to feel
safe that's your choice and if you want
to take a reasonable risk
that's also your choice of course we do
have laws like traffic laws to minimize
certain types of risk uh because we have
learned some lessons the hard way but
i think that there is a very open space
for a lot of debate about what level of
risk you allow people to think for
themselves and choose for themselves and
take that's just getting swept off the
table
over a virus that
is
even though it's imminently survivable
is routinely being compared to smallpox
which is not imminently survivable
okay
the vaccine passport that's
being introduced or that's here
do you know what differences it makes to
people so if you have the vaccine what
are you allowed to do and does that
differ by state
and if you're not vaccinated what kind
of freedoms are you losing
well
i mean in the u.s
as far as i know only the state of new
york
and maybe mostly only new york city and
then los angeles are actually
implementing these in practice so far so
like i live in tennessee we don't have i
don't
there are no coveted policies here that
have any meaning as far as i'm concerned
or i'm aware
i never wear a mask anywhere except on
airplanes um than to go through security
in an airport nowhere else and it's just
not part of my life now if i go to new
york
you know they're very strict and to get
into places you actually have to have
the vaccine and there it's down to
individual enforcement
um
so we're not all the way i know canada
is a little bit different but we're not
all the way at the level of
passports they've attempted it in new
york city i think they're about to
attempt it in los angeles and otherwise
the rest of the united states does not
have that but they do have these weird
mandates in different employment sectors
some of which are more real than others
joe biden for example does have the
authority to mandate the federal
employees who are under his purview
should be ma can be mandatorily
vaccinated um he does not however have
the authority to say that my private
company may be named amazon can mandate
i don't own amazon just full disclosure
can
mandate their employees to be vaccinated
so people think that though because of
this whole you know osha thing but it
turns out that that was just a press
release and it's so far and i know that
because there are lawyers who've been
waiting to sue the federal government
for this
mandate and they can't sue because
there's actually no official thing they
just did a press release and said that
they're going to do it and then
companies started doing it
even though there's no legal apparatus
requiring them to which sort of sucks
for those companies again safety and
trade-offs right because those companies
believe they're taking a
move that lowers their liability will
presume by enfor getting people to get
vaccinated requiring their employees to
get vaccinated if they have more than
100 employees but the legal apparatus
that would would
take away their legal responsibility if
something goes wrong was not actually
put in place so the company's gonna be
left holding the bat
that was a press release everything's
fake
this is all fake i hate to sound like a
lunatic there's so much of this i mean
after having again we can go back to the
woke literature i invoke the critical
theorists and now i'm going to invoke
the post-modernists
i'm going to invoke john bauderiard who
talked about through the 80s about this
idea of simulation simulacrum and and
hyper reality and hyper reality is this
kind of
fake reality that's more real than real
it's a it's a it's a propaganda creation
is what it is and he was thinking
largely but not entirely he was thinking
largely at the time of you know
marketing where you have the airbrushed
model and she looks hotter than hot and
it's you know
whatever
not
she looks more
more feminine than female allows in
reality because she's airbrushed and
she's you know
photoshopped into you know put a little
extra hip on her slim that waist a
little bit you know let's make those
eyes really like perfectly shine or you
know more real than real and so he was
kind of thinking of that but he also
wrote a series of essays during the gulf
war that were collected into a book
that's titled the gulf war did not take
place
and what he argues in that book is it's
not that there weren't incidents and in
fact atrocities that were taking place
in the middle east instead it's that
what we were presented with
through cnn and the other media outlets
and our governments was not what was
really taking place we were given the
truman show version of a real
thing that was happening in the middle
east and the thing that is called the
gulf war was the the
production that was his argument so
we're not looking at the real thing
we're looking at a fake creation around
the real thing that drives a narrative
and he actually in fact said that the
gulf war did not take place he said the
gulf war is an atrocity masquerading as
a war
and so
this has been picked up what's happened
is the people who are in power right now
whether it's through the woke or whether
it's in conjunction with the woke or
whether it's the so-called regime or the
overstate or this whatever we we might
want to call the hyper elites who seem
to be doing a bunch of weird stuff uh in
many countries all at once
simultaneously you know very
simultaneously to where everything seems
to be happening and once everywhere at
once
they have seen the tools in fact they've
seen the warnings that were given
by both the critical theorists and the
um post-modernists especially and said
these are weapons and they've picked
them up and they've started to use them
and so
where
baudrillard was in despair warning about
the state of the world
in which it's possible to create a hyper
real or a pseudo-real image of what's
actually happening in the world and to
manicure and control that through
propaganda and repetition and marketing
and er because he hated capitals and i'd
be marketing and everything else um
you flip that over and you get the
truman show where if you you know the
basic plot is jim carrey's character
truman doesn't know that he's actually a
character in a television show where he
lives in a town that's not even real the
whole he's lived his entire life in a
town that doesn't exist because it's
actually a sound stage
and at the end you know he ends up on a
boat and he crashes into the edge of the
soundstage and finds out that his entire
reality is fake and then the audience
watching is you know fought has 30 years
or 40 years has fallen in love with this
character uh
outside of the truman show is truman and
do they
are they aghast at the fact that
it's all fake and that they've been
manipulating truman and all that no
they're just more enthralled with this
with the the hyper real story being told
that's really kind of um
[Music]
what we're dealing with and so you know
the biden administration comes out it's
just like when they did the the
extension on the uh eviction moratorium
biden said we don't have the authority
to do this we'll just do it anyway it'll
buy us time
so from kovid they made an eviction
moratorium where you couldn't evict
people if they didn't pay their rent say
to their landlord the landlord had no
legal response to throw them out
and so it was going to expire i think at
the end of july but it may have been
june but i'm pretty sure it's the end of
july this year it was set to expire they
let it run the clock run down to a
crisis so that they could then come out
and say you know congress never acted
blah blah and then biden came out with
an executive order saying well we're
going to extend this eviction moratorium
even though it's a legislative decision
not an executive decision so he
technically couldn't do it and he said
we'll get the cdc to do it for us so
we'll use an administrative apparatus
which is under the executive branch
to do it and so they
they extended it but even said it's
unconstitute we know it's
unconstitutional for us to do it but
it'll buy us time it's all fake it's all
just manipulations they're just
completely creating a
fabrication of what's really going on
and i actually think that that we're in
a very interesting time in history
very much like after the printing press
was invented the internet being our
analog in which the powers are realizing
that the mechanisms by which they
maintained power
are literally being dissolved out from
under them and so now they're trying
desperately to use those tools whether
through selective censorship whether
through uh threatens of of banning
people from social media for saying the
wrong things for example
by trying to change definitions very
rapidly by putting things out that are
are
just as they say in professional
wrestling kayfabe um which is when you
know it's fake and the audience knows if
it's fake but you all pretend it's real
anyway um
they're doing this i think in a
desperate attempt to maintain control
and if you look at that world economic
forum stuff that i was telling people
that you go read a minute ago through
that lens all of a sudden it kind of
also makes sense
these super hyper elites realize their
power is about to be swept out from
under them and
by creating a state like you have in
china where there's total information
control you can keep that thing
under a lid
okay
so
i guess any skepticism i have towards
and i'm i'm not that skeptical but any
skepticism i have towards something like
this would be
i think the average person is
not capable of doing very much
i don't think people are that bright
and this is huge so how could
people have come together
to architect something or something this
complicated
and then have it be successful
well
um it's a very interesting question uh
the answer is that they basically played
upon the people who have the right
access to power in the right ways and in
particular uh because of say in the
united states and i know things are a
little different in canada
our constitution makes it very difficult
for these kinds of things to have been
put into place but the corporations can
do a lot of things that the government
can't for example twitter can curtail
your speech so far because they are a
private company and that's the argument
you usually hear
um so what actually happened was there
was a collection of corporate leaders
who were brought together that's what
the world economic forum is
who met in this davos switzerland and
they came together and they had all of
these visions for how they could shape
society and go forward but more
importantly
the large banking institutions started
to bake into their programs
things that would make sure that that's
how
capitalism or business plays out so
for example all of the big leading
lenders and asset managers blackrock
vanguard
uh wells fargo goldman sachs etc all
require adherence to what they would
call
environmental social and governance
measurements esg metrics and esg metrics
are defined in terms of sustainable
development goals
so the goal is to make a sustainable
world which sounds great on paper until
you realize that it means a
heavily managed administered economy by
a technocratic oligarchy in other words
socialism
in a new form neo-socialism is a better
way to phrase it because it's not
old-school socialism it's something
completely different and so if you want
to have your assets managed or to do
business with one of those major
lenders or even through a central bank
you better have a proper esg score so
there's been in effect a social credit
score
put into place for these big companies
and the model they were sold was that
corporations have lost their way
they're no longer being socially
responsible so that we have responsible
governance models put into place and
we're going to shift a little bit at
first out of this idea that the
corporation's primary obligation is to
its shareholders which are the people
who own stakes in the company into
something broader called stakeholders
which involve all of these people who
are say technocrats who say you know
what we have a stake in what your
exxonmobil does and with regard to
pollution with regard to environmental
controls we the people of whoever you
know whether it's you know some
representative of the un whether it's
some john kerry or something has a stake
and what happens with the climate
so exxon mobil we're going to score you
in terms of your ability to have your
assets managed and moved and to be able
to do business at the highest levels in
accordance to whether your environmental
score is good and we have to be socially
responsible we can't keep using
capitalist methods to generate
large-scale social and economic
inequities so we have to implement a
social responsibility score under the
social metric and if you want to know
how to do best practices under this new
system the stakeholder system you're
going to have to have best practices in
company governance and so that's the
governance score and so the way that it
happened was people largely thinking
most of them involved probably thought
they were doing something good and maybe
all of them did i don't even necessarily
want to say oh schwab evil maybe he is
maybe he is i don't know i'm not going
to just point at somebody and say evil
for sure what i'm going to say is even
if it started out good it just it's a
it's a ball that is rolled down the hill
to the point now where it's actually
causing problems and nobody's willing to
back out
um
it got out of control because
power corrupts over time as it tends to
do and most of this power being that it
was done through non-governmental
organizations ngos
in conjunction with state leaders and
corporate leaders is unaccountable power
i can't get pissed off and go vote klaus
schwab out of the world economic forum
it's his
entity i don't know if it's a non-profit
whatever it is it's his entity i can't
vote him out i have no accountability
there
i can't cast my vote for george soros
not to fund the african-american policy
forum which is dumping critical race
theory into the
into into society at an alarming rate i
have no say over where george soros
throws his money
is he [ __ ] that yes he is the chief
funder of the african-american policy
forum which is run by kimberly crenshaw
which is uh who is the person who named
critical race theory
in 1989 in the first place
i don't know why this makes me laugh
it turns out you don't need very many
people if they come up with a way to get
a whole bunch of other people thinking
they're doing the right thing while
you're actually leading them around by
the nose you just don't need very many
people
and they don't even have to be
coordinating
george soros can have his agenda with
all of his money and be leading people
in a particular direction and klaus
schwab or christine lagarde at the
international monetary fund can be doing
in there and they're in cahoots for sure
i mean they openly like
introduce each other and cite each other
and appear together frequently
they can have their own agenda and those
might run kind of in parallel they might
feed off of each other they might
sometimes support each other they might
sometimes partner and sometimes not the
koch brothers or there's only one left
dip in and out of this
for example sometimes they're in it and
sometimes they're not uh
so it doesn't take very many people to
start creating a situation where lots of
money and lots of opportunity and i
think the opportunity is bigger than the
money
for example what is the world economic
forum it's an it's an opportunity what
is davos what is that meeting in davos
it's a it's a place for all the biggest
movers and shakers in the world to get
specially invited to come to this super
cool thing
that's going to be lavish and exciting
and fun and you know whatever and rub
elbows and network with one another
networks are really the thing of the
21st century at least for the time being
and given being given access to rub
elbows with other super smart and
powerful people
as long as you kind of play by the
overarching rules that get you in the
room in the first place
creates an incredible pressure to get
people to go along with something that
it sounds exciting and new and good and
fun and you need very few people if any
who are actually genuinely evil or
agenda driven to really set the tone the
person who's inviting you like do you
need anybody do you need anybody evil
there or could this be a bunch of
influential people that are trying to do
good and just it could be that yeah it
could actually be that and then you can
imagine though that if there are any
evil people present at all
then that that's going to be the thing
but it's very it it becomes a country
club like
it's like that the country club like
davos is that the davos set is like the
country club of country clubs of country
clubs it's the who's who and i'm
important and i'm big and special or it
has been for many many years and so
all of a sudden you can create within a
country club you always end up creating
an echo chamber especially of values of
what those people espouse what they see
in the world what they want to do and
you can just very easily imagine
where um there's no pied piper
necessarily this is actually a thing in
psychology that's known as the abilene
paradox uh where everybody thinks that
everybody else wants to go in a
particular direction but nobody
necessarily does so they all just kind
of walk together you can imagine like if
you and a bunch of friends nobody really
wanted to go to taco bell but somehow it
was like are we going to taco bell and
yeah i thought we were oh and nobody
wants to be the one to speak up and say
what no
and so all of a sudden you know four or
five of you are at taco bell at two in
the morning and you're like how did we
get here everybody's privately thinking
how did we get here
but
it's probably waffle house at 2am but um
you know
nobody actually wanted to go but
everybody went so there doesn't
necessarily have to be a pied piper but
you can imagine how much worse it is if
there is a pied piper if say klaus
schwab has this weird agenda and he says
well the people i'm going to invite to
this hyper elite special thing are
people who i can get to go along with my
agenda and if they stop i won't invite
them anymore or i'll cut them off at the
knees in some other way or i'll mobilize
the group to
excommunicate them you create the exact
kinds of social pressures that human
beings are
susceptible to at the most tribal level
and you can create
a cabal around an agenda very easily
that might the conspiracy might be
literally one person and everybody else
is just going along because they want to
stay in the social club
that would be
crazy it's just an entire pyramid one
person at the top
yeah i encourage people to read klaus
schwab's books they're not hard to read
he is a
we'll say visionary with our tongue
planted firmly in our
cheek he's had a very clear vision for
the world through a fourth industrial
revolution which is going this kind of
big points our fourth industrial
revolution in which we are going to move
away from a labor-based economy more or
less entirely everything will be
automated and the problem that they're
then trying to solve is this creates a
many billion strong useless class to be
compared against the creative class that
gets to do the creative and fun things
while machines do the vast majority of
the work so what do you do with those
people well you need methods of social
control and management because they have
nothing to work for how do you justify
paying them well we need universal basic
income blah blah blah blah
that's
a thing so you have the idea of a fourth
industrial revolution he has this idea
of a public private partnership that's
running a stakeholder or an impact
capitalism
and that's where you end up with your
esg stuff now you have stakeholders who
are going to judge how corporations are
going to do things we're going to
reinvent
we're going to reinvent capitalism to be
run
through this kind of technocratic means
to these you know un unelected experts
in some kind of a stakeholder meeting
rather than through shareholders who
actually have skin in the game in terms
of what the company is
doing in terms of making a success or
not
he has another idea that what we're
going to go toward in terms of
sustainability is what he calls a
circular economy
this has been warned about by leftists
since the 1960s and specifically the
neo-marxists in the 1960s were warning
that consumer capitalism it said meets
people's needs they were admitting that
capitalism works once you control for
trusts of certain kinds
so if you control for trust capitalism
meets people's needs and they said well
what happens is if you meet people's
basic needs they get new needs
and those needs become less and less
needy in some sense and so then you
create an arbitrary kind of false
economy that's just people producing
stuff people don't need
so that people can buy stuff that they
don't really want and then if we look at
that as a level of false needs then
there's a you know this just continues
and continues and continues until
finally the entire thing becomes
unsustainable we we exhaust the the
world of its resources or we exhaust
people completely and they are unaware
that their that capitalism is on an
unsustainable growth course so i would
say as somebody who studied
mathematically epidemiology and
mathematical ecology when i was in
graduate school that they don't
understand how carrying capacities
actually affect
real populations and that these things
actually do have a nice natural smooth
curve the the curves are almost always
sigmoid in shape and the this these
kinds of population dynamics are not
actually
unmanageable exponential catastrophes
where everything destroys itself in the
end it we tend not to actually
populations tend not actually to destroy
themselves by overpopulation unless
maybe you're talking about bacteria or
something that has absolutely no
capacity to cognate so he wants to move
into a circular economy rather than a
linear or exponential economy so
everything
reduce reuse recycle everything has to
everything that comes out of the economy
has to feed back in as the next cycle
but because of the law the second law of
thermodynamics
entropy
always increases that's not really going
to work this is a
program of managed decline and if again
you read say one-dimensional man herbert
marcusa the kind of big critical
theorist of the 60s and one dimensional
man he even talks about how um and this
was in written in 1964 you know
the sustainable future requires or of
course he says of course it requires a
reduction in the future population
um because we have too many people and
it's unsustainable and you see these
things running away so now what we have
to do is just kind of just manage
decline where he says we're going to be
content with less content with less
gadgets less plastic these are actual
things he says and that we have to find
where our quality of life can be raised
in other ways rather than having
consumer capitalism drive everything off
of a cliff and so in that regard i
actually think it's driven whether these
people are evil or not is fine whatever
that's a strong word but it's driven by
lunatics who don't understand how the
world works and that they're very afraid
that we're either with the climate or
with whatever else going to create an
unsustainable situation that leads to
mass extinct mass extinction and they're
trying to save the world from that so
again we come back to this pretext of
safety
but what are we trading
have you been to china
it's an interesting country um
i've been to china for i've spent 14
weeks of my life in china and i would
not want to live there it's interesting
to visit
um
but the social credit thing is is
intense
okay james
sorry i scared the crap out of you
probably
my arms are shaking you just can't see
it on camera
yeah um yeah this is this is the uh
this is the moment
where everything is meant to be
reorganized and everything is meant to
be reorganized into one where um
social control is absolutely necessary
whether it's control of information
which they just call misinformation or
whatever through censorship or what
marcus warned us is the need for
pre-censorship less the idea even into
the head
of people who might be reactionary to
what's going on with the for him the
left agenda the new left agenda um
whether it's in
terms of you know
who did you hang out with who did you
spend time with how do you behave
whatever did you decide that you were
you know what
it's friday night i ain't got nothing to
do tomorrow i'm gonna have a good
evening you know and party it up or
whatever well that was irresponsible
now you can't like buy a plane ticket
for three weeks or whatever
there's also the element of this where
there's the gigantic
intercontinental competition uh there
are people in the west who are very
afraid that the chinese model is more
efficient and successful what we would
call deng-ism if we were trudeau
well yeah trudeau
said that
yes exactly and you hear it from other
western leaders as well um so
the model that china uses is called
deng-ism
it is a public private partnership where
they've opened up capital it was
pioneered deng as ding xiaoping it was
pioneered by deng xiaoping and the idea
was that we're going to open up the
markets but the market is going to
operate at the pleasure of the party so
jack ma can become a billionaire and do
crazy things and launch his big huge the
world's biggest new ipo but he said
something critical to the chinese party
while he was launching it and all of a
sudden his ipo doesn't get launched and
he disappears for several months when he
comes back nobody knows if he's dead but
when he finally comes back he's not a
billionaire anymore he's not really all
that rich
because he said the wrong thing because
he would against the party so what
you're actually seeing there when
they're looking over at china if you
want to put in the terms of 1984 they
see that east asia already exists
but we don't have oceania to go up
against it so they have to create
oceania on this side so that it can
always be at war with east asia um so in
other words they're looking at how do we
turn the west into the they're saying
basically that freedom and democracy and
republics are too inefficient to compete
with an autocracy that has an open
market and so how do we create our own
autocracy that can move and react as
quickly and responsively to things as
say the chinese government can
while uh
not being china and so
everybody's like you know looking at the
world and they don't understand for
example that china just named george
soros a terrorist and
george soros has probably done some
things to strike back i won't speculate
too deeply on what those things are but
it was weird that it was soon after that
that their housing market took a
gigantic multi-trillion dollar hit and
which is a very george soros kind of
thing to do how do you sleep at night
do you sleep you get really tired and
then you just black out and have bad
dreams
okay james
where can people find you online
uh the website's newdiscourses.com i
don't i don't actually talk about this
side of stuff nearly as much as i do
just about the woke stuff because it
turns out the woke is the lock pick to
make this stuff work it's like to open
the door so we can do all this crap so i
mostly talked about the woke stuff also
that's where my literature reading is
all but that's all on new discourses.com
it's on social media in a lot of places
at new discourses go look you can find
it probably at whatever social media
place you like unless it's one of the
ones that i don't want to deal with yet
and eventually i'll expand probably by
force i'm personally on twitter at
conceptual james and i'm very irreverent
and i tweet way too much and um
welcome to the jungle if you sign up for
following me on twitter it's fun
okay thank you very much for coming on
yeah sorry to scare the living [ __ ] out
of you this episode is brought to you by
the best grill i have ever used hands
down no questions asked as you know mom
dad and i are on this beef and lamb diet
for our really awful autoimmune
disorders so we're very experienced at
cooking meat
very but i've never done it with a girl
this classy schwank grills you guys may
have thought i'd switch brands from
blazing bowl to schweig but schwank is
blazing bowl's new name i don't do
continuity errors
schwein girls are made in america
they're portable they're an infrared
grill that heats up to 1500 degrees
fahrenheit to give you that premium
steakhouse quality taste you know when
there's a crispy layer on the outside
while still being rare or medium rare on
the inside
mired reactions this girl does that but
in your backyard or on your patio
doesn't smoke it's super easy to clean
which is amazing and it makes high
quality steakhouse style steaks or
whatever else you feel like grilling
steaks take around three minutes to
grill depending on the thickness
three minutes for a restaurant style
steak but you can also do chicken wings
fish hamburgers vegetables
or you can use the pizza stone if you're
one of them pizza easers for a nice
crispy pizza in under five minutes
try their special offer by heading to
schweinkgrills.com
right now for 150 off a schweink 1500
degree grill when using promo code mp at
checkout for the code to work you must
have the schweint grill and grill cover
in your cart
that'll get you 150 off schweinkrill's
with code mp at checkout
this episode is brought to you by paleo
valley 100
grass-fed beef sticks paleo valley is
unique among protein products in the us
they're committed to making high-quality
clean products free of problematic
ingredients and free from farming
practices that are harmful to the
environment you've probably heard some
of the tricks used by companies did you
know that they can claim their beef as
grass-fed as long as it was fed grass at
one point in its life
learn something new every day or that
meat can be marked american-made even if
it's only packaged in america paleo
valley on the other hand is the real
deal their products come from small
family-owned farms
in the us that use rotational grazing
look it up i'm a huge fan of rotational
grazing and their cows are never fed
grains or harmful antibiotics so if you
avoid meat for environmental reasons
which is not a good reason to avoid meat
but if you do you're going to love these
guys
paleo valley grass-fed and finished beef
sticks
i can't quite eat these because of my
strict meat and salt diet but the
ingredients in here are amazing there
are no preservatives or fillers just 100
american 100 grass-fed and finished beef
from domestic regenerative farms and
organic spices good luck finding
anything this good if you're trying to
get healthy or lose weight an easy way
to do that is just to swap your snacks i
really recommend doing that get rid of
the chips and cookies in your house and
fill your house with
paleo valleys beef sticks
go ahead and help your body us farms and
the environment today by trying paleo
valley's high quality protein just head
to paleo valley dot com and enter code
mp for 15 off your first order that's
paleo valley dot com with code mp for 15
off your first order enjoy the rest of
the episode
arthur kaplan welcome to the podcast
thank you very much for having me
uh before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
absolutely so i'm a professor
i've been at
nyu in new york city at our medical
school for about 10 years now
and i started our program in medical
ethics bioethics
and often people are saying that's nice
what's that so
what we do is
we teach ethics courses to our medical
students that are required they learn
about informed consent privacy
the
right to refuse medical treatments
how to share
data what's permissible what isn't what
they have to report
to public health authorities in terms of
child abuse or
sadly
crimes gunshot victims that sort of
stuff
and we get into issues of rationing
health care
i think you know michaela there's been a
lot of
rationing going on because of covid of
different types of yes
and
medical resources we try to teach about
how to think about that we're interested
in assisted suicide which has been a big
issue in the united states and canada
when could you ever ask a doctor
to help a dying person die
and could that happen to a child or
someone who's
mentally disabled could they participate
in these kinds of things
and we do a lot of research sorry to
babble on about this but it just might
interest listeners so we study things
like transplants how well do people
understand organ donation when someone
says do you want to be an organ donor do
they really the family understand what's
happening are they
satisfied that they were treated well so
we'll do surveys
questionnaires interviews
we have a big project going this is kind
of interesting on uh reproductive
technologies
for example
i don't know if you know or your
listeners know but it's possible
to take sperm from a dead body sometimes
people
partners wives will say my husband who
was healthy had a terrible heart attack
out of the blue or had a stroke
and i still want to have his baby and we
can
technologically remove sperm but should
we
that man who died never said i want to
have a baby when i'm dead
there's no
permission if you will you listen to the
wife or the girlfriend and they said
well we really were trying to have the
baby yeah and you know trust us that's
what we want to do
and you're thinking
do you take that seriously so anyway
we're trying to survey both the medical
people who do it
people who come in for in vitro
fertilization treatment we're just
asking them as a kind of representative
group is this something you would know
about
think about ever do
so without taking up the whole podcast
we have a lot of fun interesting
exciting areas that we study and publish
about and we also have a master's degree
you could take a master's degree in
bioethics now at nyu
wow
okay i might have to have you back on to
do a longer podcast that sounds
fascinating a lot of interesting stuff
there
okay so i wanted to talk on this episode
specifically about the vaccine passport
issue okay the ethics behind that
so my first question here
is this vaccine the introduction of a
vaccine passport how do you feel about
that
ethically
well
you're talking to somebody who's been
pro
vaccine passports for a while now i
didn't get to this late early on i
started to say look
you're going to need to have some way to
prove you're vaccinated
if we're going to have freedom to travel
so the biggest reason to get a vaccine
passport going is
many countries are saying you can't come
in here unless you're vaccinated
i'm not going to say whether they're
right or wrong it's just how it is
so if you want to visit greece
if you want to go to well just many
countries
they're going to say
show me proof of vaccination
now the way we're stuck doing it in the
united states as you pull out these
little paper cards that you get when you
get vaccinated they're not even
laminated i mean they weren't even meant
for this purpose
so i think you need to have something
that you can stick on your passport
card or some chip or something that says
i'm vaccinated remember to many
businesses
they do international commerce big
companies they got to send their sales
people or their workforce or their i.t
people all around the world
a lot of the world is saying you can't
come here by the way that's true in the
u.s we're saying you can't enter
and you can't also immigrate unless you
have proof of vaccination so we're
looking for it as well
so better to have a standardized card
hard to forge
of you can't counterfeit
um
just for international purposes that's
probably the strongest argument
what about people who don't want to get
vaccinated
look i'm never going to make anybody get
vaccinated
you don't have to do it i'm not sending
out the vaccine police to hold you down
and sort of give you a vaccine while you
scream that you don't want it
but what happens with people who don't
want to vaccinate and this is odd
they lose some of their freedom i think
we hear a lot of debate saying i have to
be free to decide whether or not to
vaccinate i wouldn't disagree
it is your body you can decide what you
want to put in there but
if the business says you can't come in
without vaccination let's say your gym
or your restaurant or whatever it is or
your employer says look you're not
working here without vaccination and by
the way
employers are free to do that they
think about having a job they can fire
you for a thousand reasons out of the
blue
it's what we call at will
you know you're employed unless you have
a contract or some
special arrangement
you you work at the discretion of the
company if the company decides for
whatever reason
you got to be vaccinated then you can't
go there so what i'm saying is this
well we sometimes argue ethically you
have to be free to choose
okay
but remember you're going to have more
freedom
to work and go places in a world that's
starting to
expect vaccination in a lot of settings
you can make the choice say i don't care
then i won't work there and i'm not
going to go into those places that
want me to prove it okay
but i think weirdly
it's it's it's pretty likely that you're
going to get more freedom long term from
vaccinating than not
okay what about the concern whether or
not this is a conspiracy theory who
knows but what about the concern that
the vaccine passport is part of a bigger
picture and will end up with a social
credit system like china yeah
well the chinese system for listeners
don't know
they're using face recognition they're
monitoring movements all over the place
by the way
they also test your genes
they have all this genetic database on
who's a weaver and who's
not and part of the way they lock up
people they don't like is to use a
genetic test so
another show
that's
really abusive of human rights they're
monitoring their citizens day and night
if we had a vaccine passport are we
sliding down that road is basically the
worry i don't think so because i think
we can say
in the middle of a play
we need these vaccine passports
when the plague goes away we're done
with them that is we're not going to do
them anymore but we should pass
legislation that makes it clear we're
responding to covet this is not
an effort to let the state start to know
where we are
the other sad point is this and it is
sad
uh i'm holding up
right now my cell phone and people
constantly are saying to me i don't want
a vaccine passport because people will
know where i am
you know what this cell phone does it
transmits every minute where i am to a
slew of people not just hackers but my
credit card company my bank somebody
does open table and makes reservations
at rest they know where i am all the
time
this thing is a gps it tracks me
constantly
i would worry about that area of privacy
more i mean i'm on board to say we gotta
protect your privacy but the vaccine
passport is like
a one percent risk relative to
your credit card your cell phone
um your uber uh registration uh what
facebook knows about you i mean my god
there's like
there's a hundred different companies
right now that know
everything about me uh where i
look on the web where i go and we
haven't done anything about that
are you aware of so you're in new york
what's new york like if you're not
vaccinated and you don't have one of
these cards
nasty
this is a place that's very pro-vaccine
as i am
to be
honest i've been vaccinated i've even
had a third
shot i just got my flu shot
you're talking
did you get the booster shot after the
first two like after six months or
something
okay partly uh just because i'm old
enough to qualify
uh
that's really why i did it
partly because i do go to places where
there are unvaccinated people around
both well just in a lot of my job
related
work in the hospital and stuff and then
whether it's a wedding or a sporting
event i don't know who's really
vaccinated or not people say they are i
don't know maybe they are maybe they
aren't so i'm being
cautious that way all that said
new york has mandates and they are very
uh they're seriously applied i would say
a lot of restaurants bars gyms
um cafes you can't get in unless you can
show a vaccine passport unless you have
authentication they won't serve you and
they won't let you in
there have been fights about it people
have gotten into big screaming arguments
about getting in but
they do try to enforce
a city-wide mandate on access to public
places
teachers mandated
city workers mandated
they're talking now about mandating
vaccinations for prison guards and the
police
the mayor's on here constantly promoting
vaccination
but
the real test of this i mean what are we
trying to do
not just trying to vaccinate people
trying to get less disease and where i
work less people in the hospital so i
see the results of non-vaccination
because our beds are full
when the epidemic is out of control a
lot of people sick a lot of people dying
pressure on
the icu beds that we have and around the
new york hospitals right now alaska for
example is in the middle of a huge
outbreak
and they don't have enough icu beds and
they don't have enough doctors to treat
all the people coming in so it's bad
the mandates here have reduced that
the real question to me is i don't care
what the vaccination rate is what i want
to know is
are there fewer people getting sick so
so far it looks like our rates are
probably 80 vaccination and i think it's
having an impact
even the u.s
70
roughly vaccinated at this point of
adults
kids are going to be
see what happens with them soon but
they're going to become eligible
but covet is starting to get weaker
fewer cases fewer deaths i think it's
working
what do you think of the ethics behind
not pressuring people to be vaccinated
with a newer vaccine like this
especially
yeah that's a really good question so
a lot of people worry
let's see these are new vaccines
pfizer moderna
the johnson and johnson want his little
older style
vaccine that's been around a little more
that's the two-shot one
but the new you know a lot of people are
offered pfizer and moderna
and it is true that the description that
was used by then president trump for
them was warp speed
and i think a lot of people are thinking
i'm not sure i want my medicine at warp
speed or my vaccine at warp speed so
here's what's going on
i'll give you the story the vaccines
moderna and uh pfizer had are not warp
speed science
you've got uh canada had a big sores
outbreak
yeah
there were murs outbreaks different
diseases they're all cousins to covet
they're all in that same what's called
the sars family of viruses
and they were working on these platforms
to make vaccines for about 10 years
they'd already done the animal studies
they'd tested the same technology and
healthy volunteers
that's why you were able to go fast if
we hadn't been doing that
there wouldn't have been any vaccines to
approve because they would have had to
start from scratch and start animal
studies and all this so they've done all
that
what's warp speed
is
the us government said we're going to
buy vaccines from you big pharma
companies
whether they work or not
you're going to get paid
big pharma company said hey
great you give us billions of dollars
we'll make a lot of these vaccines
that's the warp speed it's the
manufacturing normally would take them
forever years to commit to making
a lot of vaccine now they said you're
giving us the money whether it works or
not
we're in
happily they worked but
the speedy part is making them faster do
the companies make money they did
is there a potential to say they have a
conflict of interest in promoting
vaccination yeah you could
although i do think
we're getting a demonstration as covid
begins to
dip that they're working
did the companies get overpaid
i think so
uh should they start to be cutting the
price i think so
should they be doing something to make
vaccines available in poor countries i
think so they're not so i'm not
excusing their behavior but i don't
worry about the science
i think the science is sound and you
know at this point one other comment
a couple of billion people have had
vaccinations around the world it was
really dangerous we'd know
okay so you talked about vaccine
passports and what would be potentially
reasonable would be implementing the
passport while we're in the middle
of a pandemic and then having some of
these rights
back
potentially for and and correct me if
i'm paraphrasing wrong but having some
of these rights back maybe for
unvaccinated people once numbers are
lower yeah
i mean i think that's i think
you know look we have the flu
in any given year it might kill as many
as 25 30 000 people in the u.s i don't
know the worldwide numbers but it's not
trivial but no one's getting a passport
no one's
saying you can't come in here if you're
not vaccinated against the flu there are
days when i think
maybe we should do that just to get more
flu protection but look
all of us have to come to an agreement
i'm going to use a u.s number again 725
000 people dead in a year is too big
got to get tough
got to try and control that
25 000 people dying is a little bit more
like automobiles and we don't ban them
we just
kind of try to make it safer i'm not
saying we don't
do anything but
we live with the fact that a lot of
people die in car accidents and that's
how it is and that's what we do with the
flu if we could drive covey down to that
level
then i think we're kind of out of the
woods and we don't have to have special
laws and mandates and
religious exemptions and all these
fights we're getting into
it's that big number
close to 750 000 people dead
a hospital system in around the world
that's been hugely strained very
expensive
um think about the economic impact you
know we tried to do quarantines and
lockdowns in many countries like new
zealand australia the world economy
almost fell apart
um that's that's a much bigger
problem that makes me want to do a
bigger
response if you will
to have vaccine passports and
pro-vaccination it's the numbers
what happened so you you think that the
vaccines are helping i feel like and i'm
not not aware of the numbers i thought
in canada and i could be wrong but i
thought that the numbers were rising
again and i think we have an about an 80
vaccination rate
but
so should we be looking at numbers or
should we be looking at how severe the
disease is
so in the u.s
40 reduction in hospitalizations in the
past couple of weeks
and
many fewer
cases although we don't really have a
national testing program so it's a
little hard
to say are there fewer infected people
we're basically tracing to answer your
question symptoms
who uh sick enough to get to the
hospital because that's where we have
numbers so that is the measure
okay and there's been a reduction in the
last yeah it's really
shifting you see it um
[Music]
and by the way i'm going to confess to
something else
there's a lot of vaccination out there
but something else has happened there
are also a lot of people who got coated
and have some naturals yeah yeah yeah so
i i had covered twice
did you
yeah it was fairly unpleasant yeah how i
was gonna say what what happened what
was your experience
the first time i was sick for about two
and a half weeks but it was really not
that bad i had a fever off and on and i
it really wasn't that bad i have a
toddler so i get some of the horrible
things she drinks yeah sure they're
little little agents of infection yeah
yeah gross but anyway so the first time
it wasn't that bad and then i was like
okay i'm gonna be immune for a while and
then i got it again about a year later
and it was quite nasty it was about two
weeks so it didn't last for as long but
i had a wheeze i didn't end up in the
hospital i wasn't taking any medication
or anything but i was completely wiped
out and i still don't have my sense of
smell or taste back and i had it in june
so one other reason to worry about covid
as you think about vaccination versus
and whatever the risks and worries are
about that versus coven
my wife got it too and she was uh
infected before we had vaccines she runs
a huge hospital here in new york the
bronx va he went to work every day
pre-vaccination she was around plenty of
people who were infected
she got it hasn't had her
uh full
sense of smell and taste restored even
now it's been over how long no
it's not right here she's tires easily i
think we don't understand yet what this
damn virus does long term to the people
who get i'm not saying
it's the same for everybody
she's older than you so maybe younger
people do better but
uh you know this people have underlying
diseases they're more prone to get
complications i worry that covent
infection might
trigger bad responses in someone with ms
or diabetes or other things we don't
know we just don't know so that could be
an additional
reason to go for the vaccine even if
you're like oh i don't know i don't like
vaccines
you don't want to get stuck with this
long-term covet problem
yeah the so some of the arguments you
hear on the other side are
questions about the efficacy of the
vaccine so whether or not it's actually
helping because say in in canada well
how many what percentage of the people
in hospitals that end up in hospitals
are vaccinated is this actually reducing
the severity of symptoms are we sure
about that
yeah we're sure
that
if you look i'm in connecticut where i
live
here's the number in the icu
vaccinated people
are uh excuse me unvaccinated people are
there
at a frequency of 50 times vaccinated
people
wow so it's huge
you're not going to get in the icu if
you vaccinate i'm not saying you
wouldn't get some symptoms i'm not
saying people can't catch it
and but it's it really
it makes you less sick by the way you
know something interesting that's
exactly what the flu vaccine does people
say to me all the time i got vaccinated
i got the flu
and i say to them so how long were you
sick and they said i don't know a day
most people get the flu out of it for
five days they're bedridden they got
aches and pains
it's miserable
yeah you can still get the flu but part
of what these vaccines are doing is
if the body's immune system can't be
bumped up enough
to
fight off completely the virus it still
helps to diminish the symptoms so
that's a that's one for the vaccines
there i think but yeah we really do know
the numbers there because we can survey
who's in the icu we know
should there be exemptions for people
who have natural immunity and is natural
immunity more effective at
fighting covid than yeah
well here's something bananas the same
mechanisms of natural immunity or what
you get out of a vaccine they're
operating the same way it's not like
natural for immunity is better
than
vaccine immunity it's not like that's
unnatural
you're using the same
cells to try and get an immune response
it's it's weird
so i uh like i said i don't really know
what i'm talking about but i thought
that the vaccine worked and it only
provoked part of an immune response
compared to
contracting covid is that wrong
i know what you're asking there
so when you get the disease you might
trigger
let's say there are five parts of your
immune system there are t cells and b
cells and all kinds of stuff that we
don't have to get into here
and when you get sick if you get a big
exposure to covid you probably get them
all triggered
if you only get a little exposure you
walk by somebody a couple
a few viruses get into you you're not
setting that all off oh if you get the
vaccine it does set off all of the uh
immune responses so the argument is you
might have partial protection in some
instances
natural infection true
but you're going to get the full ride if
you take the vaccine because the way
it's designed is to
basically set off the whole immune
response so that's what the difference
is are there people out there
maybe you who had you know serious
exposure to covet and twice whose immune
system is operating about the same level
as a vaccine could be
there are other people though who they
just get a sniffle they don't even know
they got infected i don't think their
immune system was
triggered fully they didn't have enough
virus to set the whole thing off so
that's where the
argument is are there people
who probably don't need it yeah but it's
interesting too you know we're talking
about third shots
some people say well the vaccine isn't
that good if it needs a third shot what
the heck didn't work
i think it's a three-shot vaccine
for listeners who've had any vaccines
if you get hpv vaccine for cervical
cancer which young women and boys do
it's three shots
spaced out over a year and a half
if you get a vaccine for hepatitis which
is a great vaccine to get because you
really don't want to damage your liver
spaced out three shots polio vaccine
which by the way isn't really a vaccine
it's an oral thing but it's four things
for kids over i don't know two years
my point being
when we developed these vaccines we were
so desperate to get something that would
stop deaths that they gave one shot
waited two weeks and gave the second one
that's not enough
maybe what we're just talking about is a
three shot vaccine which is one of the
reasons i decided to get the third shot
i don't even think of it as a booster i
think we were in such a hurry to get
these things out there and they worked
at least they stopped the initial wave
of covid
okay ethically i agree
but it could be that we need three shots
to make this thing work and then we can
argue about boosters but if the three
shots give you immunity for three years
five years
that's what you want i don't know about
you but almost everybody has had a
tetanus shot in their life even that
needs a booster ten years yeah
yeah
i think i i was tested recently for i
can't remember i can't remember i think
it was part of the mmr vaccine
one of them had worn off
they do they do
you normally don't worry about it
because there's so little measles and
mumps floating around that you know when
you get reminded about those when you
travel
if you went in and said i'm going to go
to mozambique or i've got which i did a
couple years ago i got a
medical trip and a vacation lined up
there every booster was i must have had
this will terrify listeners i think i
had like eight shots
you know typhus typhoid
all kind of yellow fever
i didn't worry me too much because those
are pretty well
established vaccines but they were all
basically boosters
okay that's fair yeah well going to some
of those places i can understand why
yeah
having been there by the way i fully
understand why now a lot of disease
yeah
okay you
i believe wrote an article
about people who were refusing to
potentially people who refused to take
the copenhag 19 vaccine
being held financially liable
is that something you still believe yeah
yeah
i still do and here's why
if you knew that your
kid was covered positive
and you sent them to school
and the people they sat next to their
kids got sick
you ought to be responsible for the
decision not to keep them home
or you know
say uh
at least you got to go in with a mask or
maybe even notify the class that my
kid's positive but coming in anyway
so what i was talking about is people
who deliberately
[Music]
know they're sick but still go to work
or still go to school
we have a lot like that in the us i'm
not sure about canada if you know that
you are hiv positive
and you still have sex with somebody
you're liable
if they get they're trying to are they
trying to i've heard somewhere that that
was trying to be appealed
yeah maybe it could be there haven't
been many
prosecutions because the situation
happily is rare
you got to be kind of a malignant idiot
to do that but uh yeah it comes up a
little bit too
we had a big uh trial here the r kelly
trial remember that the guy yeah yeah
so a lot of the women said he gave me
herpes and he knew he was positive
and that became part of the lawsuit
so i'm in that spirit that's what i'm
talking about here it's like i'm not
saying
just anybody wandering around but if you
knew
that you were sick and you went in and
sat in a small office with somebody and
they got sick and they
sort of said well the only person that's
positive that i've been around is you
that's where you might get some
liability
um
do you do you think that the vaccine
passport
ethically
okay so you're not you're not allowed
and i think it's in the constitution but
i could be wrong because i'm not
american but
you're not allowed to ask for health
data right that's your personal data so
do you think the vaccine passport
crosses into that territory no
so we have a privacy law
hip-hop that was passed 1996.
it actually was passed before google
it's way out of date by the way but the
only thing it applies to is what doctors
and nurses and health care workers can
release
it has no
authority
over what the state or the city can ask
you for or
if you choose to give out health
information anyway so a doctor is told
you can't release records you can't
say anything about
you know michaela's care it's private
you need your permission i mean they
could do it if you said okay
and plenty of people bill clinton
went in the hospital yesterday for some
sort of infection we're not going to
know much about his care unless he says
you can tell people that's what the law
governs doctors and hospitals
but there's no hipaa protection
if the mayor says you're going to have
to show a passport to get into this
restaurant the law was never
intended as a general privacy law
it was about medical records by the way
paper records i mean
that law is so old it's so bad when he's
updated and we could argue about whether
it should be extended
wherever you go or what the police could
demand and so on
but right now it's a very narrow
misunderstood law it applies to me i'm
not supposed to tell you if we had a
celebrity patient that they're there in
the hospital or
you know that somebody has
been raped or had a mental illness or
something like that i don't know what
the canadian equivalent is i just don't
know
i think it's probably something similar
yeah but a lot of these privacy what i'm
saying is a lot of these privacy laws
were enacted before you got a fitbit
and we're sending health information off
to a company are they
prohibited from sharing that no they're
not a doctor they're not a hospital i
guess they could sell it they could
you know call you up and say i think you
need to get a little more sleep there
michaela we're looking at your uh
monitoring device we don't like what
we're you know what i mean it's sort of
like it's a free fire zone
are they trying to implement qr codes or
anything in new york
no we have not seen that yet
everything's paper everything's paper
and easy to counterfeit and there are
counterfeits
going on out there they've prosecuted a
few
people i am told by some of my students
that it would take you about 30 minutes
to make a pretty good counterfeit of a
covid card so
you know that's an issue
yeah yeah
okay that and then this this is
definitely an issue while traveling too
i was in dubai and everyone's vac state
like did mass vaccination there
everyone's vaccinated there and you need
a vaccine to get into the country i
think israel was the same
israel backtrack on that did they
mandate it and then backtrack
they sort of rolled out vaccine in waves
so they tried to the elderly that wasn't
enough then they started to adults then
they started their kids so they've had
waves of vaccination
but they're pretty much up to the 100 by
the way dubai and the emirates they're
an interesting case study because i
don't think they've had much in the way
of
people in the hospital
yeah
they haven't
but they uh when i was there they said
they just like there was a stadium and
people just went in and got vaccinated
you had to get vaccinated for your job
or they just kicked you out of dubai
they're like well you don't have to work
here
right and remember one other thing in
countries like dubai or israel
they're all part of a national health
system
the issues about privacy are less
worrisome to them because they already
have all your medical information it's
run by the government
they can peek in and look at anything
they damn well want
israel too
so there's no divide between health care
over here and government over there
basically the government's running the
health system the government pays for
your health care and they're looking all
the time at what's going on
in terms of cost and payment and so if
they want to
i'm sure they can
look at anything they like about your
health
yeah fair enough okay
so i have other questions for you
i don't i don't think so i think that
kind of covers your view pretty well i
know you have a heart out
uh i might want to bring you back on to
talk bioethics
one area we didn't talk about is what
about alternative medicines and
approaches to coven yeah let's do that
let's do that
and i'm
you know familiar with something some
things i hate because i don't think they
really
work that there's not evidence for
example that if you took ivermectin this
deworming pill
yeah
there's no reason to think that a pill
that's aimed at killing worms is going
to kill viruses i mean it just doesn't
make sense i know there are a lot of
people swear by it a lot of people say
yeah better
uh
but
scientifically
what kills worms doesn't kill viruses
and at least the
published data that's out there
doesn't really see any benefit from
ivermectin on the other hand if somebody
said to me i want to use something to
boost my immune system personally i
think that's hard to do
but it doesn't hurt you and if you want
to do that okay
i like alternative medicine things that
i think are
safe so to speak neutral they don't make
you sicker maybe some people feel they
get benefit and that's fine by me if you
want to do aromatherapy or
you have massage or whatever that i mean
you know those sound nice
uh are they gonna kill viruses i doubt
it but
you know okay
so i think medicine can work with
alternative approaches alternative
ideas health foods whatever
you just don't want to have people
promoting
certain drugs that are out there
ivermectin is one of them it is an
approved drug but it's for warm killings
that isn't
that isn't where you want to go uh the
thing that helps your sheep or your cow
is probably not the thing that's going
to be right for you to uh battle covid
and when a court says this patient wants
it
my attitude is we don't give it because
it's more dangerous than it is helpful
what about antibody infusions
they work they absolutely do work
probably with them
expensive so you could go to them and
people are getting them
uh these are the things that basically
are
building in antibodies the way hopefully
a vaccine
or natural infection would produce them
you're just
making them and putting them in
but they work it's just they probably
cost
twenty thousand dollars you have to get
an iv it's a whole
song and dance i know some people seem
to think that's better
than getting a vaccine but
that's a trade-off i don't like i'd
rather get the vaccine than be sitting
there
in the clinic a couple of times to get
antibody infusion
well in any event if you let me out i'm
happy to come back and rant off yeah
i'll let you out i'll let you out thank
you very much for coming on here it was
a pleasure
thank you for having me
[Music]
you